notre billet science qui nous conduit en
afghanistan aujourd'hui une épidémie de
rougeole a déjà frappé des dizaines de
milliers de personnes et en a même tué
plus de 150 en janvier dernier l'oms
estime que le nombre de morts pourrait
encore augmenter cette épidémie se
propage alors que le pays est enfoncé
vous savez dans une profonde crise
économique et financière depuis
l'arrivée les talibans à kaboul en août
dernier depuis le gel aussi de fonds à
l'étranger on en parle avec vous julia
cigare bonjour julia la rougeole une
maladie virale hautement contagieuse
absolument c'est une maladie qui tire
son nom bien sûr des plaques rouges qui
apparaissent qui sont caractéristiques
et c'est une maladie qui touche à 97%
les enfants ça peut créer énormément de
complications notamment des encéphalites
des diarrhées aiguës ou encore la cécité
ou des infections respiratoires sévères
alors plus généralement et c'est un
problème c'est que ça crée en fait une
suppression du système immunitaire voire
même ce qu'on appelle une amnésie
immunologique ça veut dire quoi eh bien
ça veut dire qu'on va être plus sensible
à tous les pathogènes même pour ceux
pour lesquels on a développé par le
passé une immunité alors selon l oms
effectivement les cas de rougeole sont
en augmentation sur dans toutes les
provinces du pays et ce depuis juillet
2021 en recense 60 mille quarante 2021
et si l'on fait un zoom justement sur
janvier 2022 et bien là on recense plus
de 35000 cas suspects et 150 morts et ce
sont des chiffres qui selon les
associations sont bien en deçà de la
réalité la meilleure protection contre
la rougeole aujourd'hui c'est une
couverture vaccinale très élevé car il
faut savoir que comme vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure la rougeole c'est c'est
vraiment un virus humain le plus
contagieux qui soit mais il est presque
totalement évitables grâce à la
vaccination gas grâce à ce vaccin rer
qui a été couplée avec les oreillons et
la rubéole et qui a permis selon l' oms
de d'éviter 30 millions de morts depuis
son apparition il y a vingt ans alors
lolo oms pour pour que ça fonctionne en
fait le msc explique qu'il faut qu'ils
aient une couverture vaccinale de 95% ce
qui est un objectif que aujourd'hui en
afghanistan on ne peut pas atteindre il
y à des efforts qui ont été faits
notamment par des associations avec une
campagne vaccinale en décembre qui a
permis d'immuniser environ un million et
demi d'enfants avec une distribution
massive de vitamine a qui permet de
réduire les effets et la mortalité
notamment de la rougeole mais c'est pas
suffisant pour endiguer
parlons un peu du système de santé en
afghanistan c'est l'occasion évidemment
il est en train de s'effondrer un si ce
n'est déjà fait exactement en fait il y
un il n'y a pas assez de médecins il n'y
a pas assez de médicaments et surtout il
n'y a pas assez d'hôpitaux qui soit
encore ouvert au public pourquoi parce
que seuls les établissements de santé
qui bénéficie d'un financement extérieur
sont aujourd'hui opérationnels ça fait
plus de deux décennies finalement que le
système de santé afghan est complètement
perfusé par l'aide internationale et
quand les talibans sont revenus au
pouvoir en août
2021 et bien justement il y a eu des
sanctions il ait eu des gels des avoirs
et donc vous avez certains médecins par
exemple aujourd'hui du service public
qui ne sont pas rémunérés alors il ya
aussi cette histoire vous le savez lors
de la prise des talibans les etats-unis
ont décidé de geler en fait l'équivalent
de 7 milliards d'actifs de la réserve
fait des réserves nationales afghanes
qui étaient détenus aux états unis et
aujourd'hui il ya seulement quelques
jours joe biden vient d'annoncer qu' il
allait allouer la moitié de cette somme
en fait à l'aide humanitaire en
afghanistan et l'autre moitié pour
indemniser des victimes du 11 septembre
alors évidemment ça fait énormément
polémique parce que les personnes qui
sont sur place les associations estiment
que tout cet argent devrait être alloué
à l'aide humanitaire parce qu'ils sont
face à une crise catastrophique une
crise humanitaire catastrophique qui se
profile mais washington explique que
c'est une façon de contourner les
talibans et de s'assurer finalement que
cet argent arrivera bien aux afghans
l'afghanistan vit effectivement une
tragédie humanitaire invraisemblable
selon l'onu la malnutrition touche plein
plus d'un afghan sur 2 ha aujourd'hui
effectivement et je pense que c'est le
problème le plus important aujourd'hui
la malnutrition qui menacent à 23
millions d'afghans donc c'est plus d'un
afghan sur deux il faut savoir qu'il ya
16 millions de dhs enfants qui ne
mangent pas à leur faim aujourd'hui
c'est préoccupant parce que la
malnutrition c'est un problème en soi
mais parce que aussi encore une fois ça
réduit l'immunité face à la rougeole
mais aussi face à d'autres problèmes par
exemple la dengue par rapport le
paludisme ou encore des diarrhée aqueuse
aiguë toutes les maladies aussi qu'ils
sont transmissibles par les eaux et
notamment les eaux contaminées j'imagine
qu'il faut ajoute à cela comme c'est le
cas un peu partout d'ailleurs dans le
monde la pandémie trio la fin et ce qui
est intéressant ici c'est que et bien et
cette pandémie de kobe de 19 à les
relayer au second plan tant justement la
situation est dit ici vous avez plus que
cinq hôpitaux dans tout le pays qui
reçoivent des des patients du coc vie de
19,1 seul vous le voyez ici à kaboul et
là encore il n'y a pas assez de médecins
pas assez de médicaments mais aussi de
temps en temps on ne peut même pas
chauffer les hôpitaux la situation a
priori selon certains médecins sur place
sans pire mais encore une fois on n'a
aucune donnée tout simplement parce
qu'ils n'ont pas de tests diagnostiques
je pourrais vous donner des chiffres
mais ça n'aurait absolument aucun sens
l'om s affirme aujourd'hui que il
s'apprête à envoyer des kits de
diagnostic en afghanistan d'ici la fin
du mois merci beaucoup julia siguer pour
l'éclairage en coin